people asked me Stephen did you always
intend to start a course and actually no
it was only when I figured out the
astounding amount of money these people
make but I realized I deserve part of
the pie but as my ambition grew so did
my grade and eventually as I realized
how many cars and Lamborghinis I would
need to buy in order to fill this deep
void in my heart I realized I needed the
whole pie
that's when Operation fake guru first
began by systematically discrediting my
business rivals I knew that soon people
would be asking me Stephen who is the
real guru well finally ready to answer
that question me I'm your real guru the
one true Sifu and today I'm launching my
very first of many courses how to spot a
fake guru mastermind spots are with very
limited by how many people sign up and
it is the first and last business course
you'll ever need because if you listen
to everything I say you'll have a very
short career we call that early
retirement in the biz but before we get
into the incredible value of this course
I want to say I wasn't always this
successful I used to be homeless
that was in my old life though because
when I found the secret of spotting fake
gurus that's when everything changed for
me now I'm sure the first thing you
should be asking is how much this cost
and if you join my exclusive live
webinar I'm gonna ask you a question
first and that is how much money do you
have see this is a high ticket course
and there's many up levels so the first
thing we have to decide is where do you
fit and how can I passively aggressively
upsell you to the next level because
make no mistake this opportunity is
totally unique you don't need a penny to
start you need no prior experience and
you don't even need a college to be
healthy you don't even need a high
school degree I'm an equal-opportunity
course whatever age or stage you're in
I'm happy to take your money as long as
that money is Visa or MasterCard we
don't do American Express so how do you
become a certified Sheriff of the
Internet
well I'm gonna walk you through my
course step 1 the redit advantage now
this is a 1 million dollar value this
part of the course and this is how we
get your overinflated sense of
self-importance what you're gonna need
to become a sheriff of the internet so
I'm gonna teach you and walk you through
how to become a redditor again no prior
experience necessary module 2 the fake
guru checklist how do you know if
someone's a fake to it well with my
proprietary checklist I'll walk you
through the basics that is a 10 million
dollar value right there and module 3
fake guru capital now I'm really excited
about this this is a hundred million
dollar value and I think it's worth
every penny personally now
you're gonna be saving a lot of money
because you're gonna be spotting all
these gurus and when you save that money
you're gonna need a place to put it
now with fake guru capital we offer you
an exclusive club of cryptocurrency
investments now some would call it
gambling
I know what you're thinking Stephen
first of all that sounds amazing
obviously I want to sign up but I don't
have a hundred and eleven million
dollars like you do how do I get this
how can I afford this well lucky for you
and this is I never do this I never do
this normally I actually make people pay
a hundred and eleven million dollars I
do I mean it's what people pay everyone
pays it but for you for you in the next
eight seconds I'm willing to slash this
price by 99.999% then nine hundred
ninety seven dollars that's a one
hundred eleven million dollar value for
nine ninety seven if you click the link
subscribe and like this video
in the next eight seconds that's right
it doesn't work unless you subscribe and
like this video
in the next eight seconds then click
that link in the description box below
lock in your rate guys because as I said
after eight seconds this will go back up
to a hundred and eleven million dollars
forever spots are limited I'll see you
inside the course